[Music]
sometimes I worry that I lose that I've
lost my audience could I could make a
confession yeah because for a long time
I was thinking about writing a blog post
about this but for a very long time if
you look at all the books that I've
written
it's like book on entrepreneurship book
on physical performance book on
cognitive performance and learning the
4-hour chef etc etc it's mostly
developmental it's about improving
performance in one or more areas and now
what I've spent more and more time on
like we're spending time on it right now
is the inner game for her and the
importance of developing a keen level of
self-awareness so that you can examine
the contents of your this is going to
get super whoa for a second we're just
an assembly the contents of your
consciousness right like wherever you go
you're carrying your mind with you and
so to develop a familiarity with that I
think is the the crux skill that
underlies everything else and you and I
both know plenty of achievers who are
miserable who are pressure high
performing well known people who are
utterly miserable and to me the question
of why is that how can that be the case
is the question that I'm extremely
interested in these days and but I
worried that having built an audience
who is largely not entirely kind of go
go go rah rah rah win win win there's
nothing wrong with that but people who
are trying to develop skills and
competitive advantages and so on that
then I may lose a large portion of those
people in shifting and talking about
more of these things we'll see where it
goes but that's something that has
occurred to me and I think I'm willing
to make that trade I think I'm willing
to to take that if that's a cost of
doing business
I don't know so a couple things one the
Go Go Go
audience that you've built you this may
scare them but I mean as someone who
works with elite athletes and
professional folks and CEOs and those
things like
tell you is this is the hardest
challenge you've issued mm-hmm like and
it's not about the conceptual complexity
of what we're talking about it's about
unlocking performance is one thing
unlocking people yeah way harder way
scarier and unlocking ourselves and
creating self-awareness to me it to me
you would be remiss not to go here
mm-hmm
because you know I don't know I think
like something you said when you were
talking about we all know a lot of
narcissists and they love themselves but
that's actually not true do you know
that narcissism is the most shame-based
of all the personality disorders
narcissism is not about self-love
at all it's about grandiosity driven by
high performance and self-hatred it's
you know I define it as the shame based
fear of being ordinary and so you have
to me you have this audience that and
I'm one of them I mean like and I'm
probably an outlier I guess and it's
like me being a rush fan like but
there's always outliers like 40 40 to 50
percent female but I wish it yeah yeah
it is yeah it's it's shifted a lot in
the last handful of years yeah but I
think you know when I get invited in by
a fortune 50 CEO and you know and he or
she says look we need help we need help
with the team we need they're not asking
me to help with time productivity right
they're not helping me to set up a scrum
or agile process for software
development they're saying you know
we're at each other's throats we hate
each other it's a shame based
finger-pointing like it's all about
self-awareness and changing those
behaviors and to me you know to me the
hard thing about this this area and your
work is a lot of what I've learned from
you that has changed my life has been
not only effectiveness base but
efficiency based and so where you can
lose people with this conversation is
this is not an efficient process
yeah alright Jenna mean there's no I
don't think there's a for our
self-awareness it's live no plans to
write that yeah but I mean but like but
people would love it if you could if you
could unlock that fast but to me this is
the capstone conversation for you yeah
Jenna me like I do cuz what's it all in
for yeah you know like a bit I'm winning
I'm smart
I'm successful and I'm on my third
marriage and I don't speak to any of my
children yeah like which you see a lot
or not I see all the time yeah right
because I'm going to tell you not to
dismiss the importance of that work
that's easier yeah yeah it is easier it
is easier you know because the thing
about these conversations that you know
I end up having every time we sit down
oh there's a second time that both times
we've sat down is what what
differentiates us as a social species is
the need to be seen and known and loved
and the need to see and know and love
others and no one rides for free like we
all come into this adulthood with hard
stuff and what I would say is true about
complacency and 95% of what I see that
people call pathology is its Armour yeah
it's not its Armour it's how its
behaviors and ways of thinking that I've
developed to protect myself from being
hurt
you